okay class number six of six the final
in raleigh
McCoy serious students become
we started out
movements and then
Oh
we reviewed
nearly switch
down
he wins
begins are in alignment
and as you play with this do you want
little sweetie however involved also
over Spain
in other words this is spinning in place
and
it stays put it space that's practices
so to clean up this provision
a little bit of mind work
swing but you're visually focusing on
constantly coming back and forth
really about
that their magnetically pass each other
that single focus point
we've in the same direction
not the directions of there
it doesn't look so great if your hands
aren't on the center line we can get
that nice symmetric
they're here but it might him strip the
park there's still time low
this really led us to play
spinning these
what it takes to keep that alignment so
we can spend in Spokane same direction
like what you do here
but you won a lot of the other it's
difficult to try to keep the tiny
wrist tiny it's much easier to just
focus on butterfly where you've got 20
min sweet
and you're really visualizing that it's
like a mirror reflection boy is coming
up and running past that beer line this
is together to any better
but instead of focusing on the timing of
the risky focus on spatially wire
brushing that hairline you can then just
sort of tip that mirror line over in
position and by focusing on torso body
movement driving in the boy
especially you can
for free and so this is a nice place to
get out of that pendulum moment here
slow down butterfly
I'm same direction
and so then we
stalls
so to break down how you saw
lern stalling
our large parking method for stalling
which is a nice this next week learn but
it's not the most precise or concise way
to stop the most minimal effective way
to sell is literally just to move your
hand on boiling chase after point
so we could recover some of it
that can be a little difficult at first
so guys some exercises that make
your other wrist throw with a spacer and
angry it's also kind of just distracting
you away from having to so the idea is
to mom rap he'd get rid of soil wrap the
floyd around your wrist so this is also
doubling his practice for basic rapping
skills so you're rounding boy around
your wrist that means that you're
letting the boy head all just on the
other side of your wrist so I went
wrapping around a lot it's just falling
fast
now you can get into a rhythm here buddy
one that point that's about to be your
hand from there right it's about to get
your hand want slider hen the other
spinning that over to this side and mix
it in your wrist vigorous
and that forces you to move your hand
the amount of distance that will
naturally
at first if you might not get perfect so
you might like
my head
in sometimes
g
practice is really gonna leave space out
of the super tight
so same stalls in because you're already
practicing stalling around
over here person you're going to be
ready later on when you're actually
going to scholar about your volume arts
your other wrist
we
so this is this exercise of service
eating several links
we also so you know probably easiest we
also practice on the other side you can
also get up stop sandile he'll be the
under side side side miss that might be
a little trickier that allowed you to
get a really sharp succinct all I touch
on in class
here in video
just swinging a pendulum
and he the pigeon little high above the
horizon
so but if you sleep above the horizon
purposefully and chase your hand out
under
it
like see how once my pendulum
then I'm starting to a salsa perfectly
straight yet
you can start chasing back more and more
pushing your hand out more and more full
Oh
and this is very sharp
to those basics and we came back to this
position that we started with pendulums
from this position you can also play
with stalls there's this particularly
interesting Hillary ingress thanks doll
combo right here
it's actually pulling out of a slightly
strange place
and you're always feed back to the same
but the idea is that you're selling one
down and the bottom one
and you want what a travel of it down
it's not that
here installing the top one down and
letting
just here travel
so that by stalling
and also
see my blue
Chris been installed
install switch directions and paint
that lady's continue
with mirror image stall
to break that down give you some other
exercises we also claimed installing one
at a time so
in the center point but then also just
be spelling
see
this is another one of those ones one
year when you're stalling come across
your body you want to do a little bit of
mind work with the
my hand
this place instead of as I saw here I
don't want this handy go
yes okay so from this position you're
going green it this way so if we do this
song switch positions you can come to
the color or size version but if you do
that stall is to come back
yes offers position breathe
you take a different stuff with it to
sweep across install
and so
particularly this all your boys coming
across here that simple
fasten your hint is moving in that
direction but spinning a flower
sweet
and by following past that sweetness
my end up position where my arm is
perpendicular voice all radicular but it
happened the stakes who instantly
it happens
and
another particular
this so for people he would be
the Pels did you play
this
so
stall stall
we get solved
you
instead of doing
install
so that was a very same so stalling
and if you've stolen
pull that boy
so
installed here between defense
I toxin really care
Oh
oh so basically what will be touched on
is that like when you're viewing things
patterns there are four major parts of
stalls and people like 23 so videos for
Gannon is going an instant direction
just have a big screw beast all so that
my farm
the killer
then people start noticing our petals
petals point
they install they start
zoo
and also in Spain
you're spinning your own record spinning
in the same
in word for your sin
so for instance or the other variants
all his
and then that one who sort of started
playing with earlier is the pork
moving to the box
still stalling
mental
it replaces all the ladies here
else
alright